♪ ♪
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN AND THE
RADICAL LEFT GET READY TO RAISE
TAXES AND THE PRICE OF
EVERYTHING YOU BUY, THEIR
EFFORTS APPARENTLY KNOWN NO
BOUNDARIES.
TREASURY SECRETARY JANET YELLEN
IS PROPOSING A GLOBAL MINIMUM
CORPORATE INCOME TAX WHICH OF
COURSE WILL ONLY BE PASSED ON TO
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION NO
LONGER EVEN TRYING TO HIDE THAT
THESE TAX HIKES ARE GOING TO
HURT THE MIDDLE CLASS.
OVER HERE ON FAKE NEWS CNN,
ENERGY SECRETARY ASKED ABOUT
A "WALL STREET JOURNAL" ARTICLE
THAT SAYS TAXES WILL "HIT THE
MIDDLE CLASS HARD."
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE TAX CODE IS NOT FAIR AND
SO WHAT JOE BIDEN WANTS TO DO IS
TO SAY CORPORATION SHOULD PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE IN THE SAME WAY
THAT A PLUMBER AND TEACHER WOULD
HAVE TO PAY 22% OF THEIR INCOME
OR 24% OF THEIR INCOME.
CORPORATIONS SHOULD HAVE TO PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE TOO.
>> Sean: SHE DIDN'T DENY THE
TAXES WILL HURT THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
HERE WITH REACTION, TEXAS
SENATOR TED CRUZ.
STILL MONITORING THAT CAR CHASE
IN CALIFORNIA.
SENATOR, CORPORATIONS DON'T PAY
TAXES, I ARGUE COME OR VERY
LITTLE.
WHAT THEY WILL DO IS THEY WILL
INCREASE THE COST OF THE PRODUCT
OR SERVICE IF THEY HAVE.
JUST LIKE ENERGY PRICES ARE
GOING UP BECAUSE OF BIDEN'S
POLICIES.
THAT'S ANOTHER TAX ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THOUGHTS.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW I'M REMINDED
OF WHAT HILLARY CLINTON'S HEAD A
FEW YEARS AGO.
SHE SAID DON'T LET ANYBODY TELL
YOU A CORPORATION OR BUSINESS
WILL GIVE YOU A JOB.
WELL, THESE ARE FOLKS THAT DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THE ECONOMY
WORKS.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE PEOPLE OF
TEXAS WANT?
WE WANT JOBS, WE WANT MORE JOBS
AND HOW DO YOU GET JOBS QUESTION
LIKE YOU CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE SMALL BUSINESSES CAN GROW
AND EXPAND AND HIRE PEOPLE.
WE HAVE JUST COME OUT OF A
YEAR-LONG PANDEMIC THAT HAS
HAMMERED SMALL BUSINESSES ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WHAT DO JOE BIDEN AND HIS
LEFTIST CRONIES IN THE CABINET
WANT TO DO?
EVERYONE OF THEM WANTS TO RAISE
YOUR TAXES.
THEY WANT TO JACK UP THE TAXES
ON AMERICAN FAMILIES.
ON EVERY SMALL BUSINESS IN
AMERICA AT THE EXACT TIME THAT
MILLIONS OF SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
HANGING ON BY A THREAD.
THEY ARE RIGHT AT THE EDGE
BETWEEN GOING BANKRUPT AND
SURVIVING.
WITH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING IS GIVING A SHOVE.
THE EARLY PROJECTIONS ARE THIS
BIDEN TAX INCREASE, THE BIGGEST
TAX INCREASE IN A GENERATION IS
EXPECTED TO ALMOST IMMEDIATELY
COST 150,000 JOBS AND
POTENTIALLY A LOT MORE AFTER
THAT.
>> Sean: SENATOR, IT'S THE
BIGGEST TAX INCREASE IN 30
YEARS.
NOW JANET YELLEN WANTS OF GLOBAL
MINIMUM TAX RATE.
WE SEE PEOPLE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, ILLINOIS.
THEY ARE GOING TO STATES LIKE
YOURS, TEXAS, FLORIDA AND THE
CAROLINAS.
IF THERE IS A GLOBAL CORPORATE
MINIMUM TAX, ISN'T THE IDEA THAT
CORPORATIONS LEAVE BIG CITIES
FOR TAX FRIENDLIER STATES LIKE
TEXAS, THEY MIGHT START THINKING
ABOUT LEAVING THE UNITED STATES.
ISN'T THAT WHAT THAT'S ABOUT?
>> LOOK, AND GOVERNMENT
SOCIALISTS WANT TO TAX EVERYBODY
ALL THE TIME.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR AND
MECHANISMS TO KEEP RAISING
MONEY.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY THINK THEY CAN
SPEND YOUR MONEY BETTER THAN YOU
CAN.
THAT THEY HAVE ALL OF THESE BIG
IDEAS.
YOU LOOK AT JOE BIDEN'S SUPPOSED
TO INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
OVER $2 TRILLION.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE GOES TO BUILDING
ROADS AND BRIDGES?
5%.
95% OF HIS INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
IS SPENDING MONEY ON THINGS
OTHER THAN ROADS AND BRIDGES.
THIS IS A SHELL GAME AND THE
SHELL GAME, IT ALWAYS ENDS WITH
THE SAME TRICK.
YOUR TAXES GO UP.
ON YOUR WAGES, ON YOUR SMALL
BUSINESS, ON YOUR EMPLOYER, AND
THE BIG GOVERNMENT SOCIALISTS
TAKE THE MONEY THEY SPEND IT ON
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
THEY SPEND IT ON THEIR OWN
SPECIAL INTEREST PROJECTS.
LOOK, I'M A BIG BELIEVER WHEN
OUR ECONOMY HAS TAKEN A HARD
HIT, THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
THE WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
DESERVE TO GET MORE OF THEIR
PAYCHECK IN THEIR OWN POCKETS.
WE HAD, PRIOR TO THIS PANDEMIC,
WE HAD THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT
IN 50 YEARS.
IT WAS INCREDIBLE THE ECONOMIC
BOOM WE HAD AND THAT CAME FROM
LOW TAXES AND LOWER REGULATIONS.
WHAT DOES JOE BIDEN WANT TO DO?
HIGH TAXES, HIGH REGULATIONS.
THAT IS DESTROYING YOUR JOB.
IT'S BAD FOR THE COUNTRY AND WE
ARE GOING TO SEE A WHOLE LOT
MORE THAT OVER THE NEXT TWO
YEARS UNFORTUNATELY.
>> Sean: I DOUBT THAT THE
STATE OF TEXAS IS GOING TO GET A
REFUND FOR ALL THAT'S GOING ON
AT THE BORDER D